il y a eu
des personnages féminins incroyablement puissants dans les bandes dessinées pendant des
décennies et des décennies, donc nous avons toujours à
l'esprit où pouvons-nous amener une
femme puissante de la page des bandes dessinées à
l'écran
natasha n'est pas exactement une joueuse d'équipe mais
elle sait qu'elle appartient  avec les
Avengers - vous savez que ça a toujours été une
colonne vertébrale et elle a toujours été très fermée
et nous pouvons voir un peu ce
qu'il y a derrière ce gommage voir je suis
ce qui est une diminution
Joss est vraiment intéressé à créer
un autre personnage féminin qui est fort
un tel personnel de soutien de buste Jana aventure à
travers Scarlet Witch the Black Widow
était comme élargir le monde pas de
tsubasa
aggravant cette diva Je pense que
cela rend le public plus investi dans
l'avenir de ces personnages, donc c'est
plutôt cool
vous